All right. Hey, hi, I'm Tom Sigur.
I'm going to answer the internet.
Um.
All right. If you could have any two people fight and I know rules,
cage match, who would you choose? Um,
would choose like, like Brock Lesnar and, uh,
what was that little gymnast? Simone bile. Yeah.
I used to be funny. a, I should do that answer again.
I would like to see Garth Brooks take on
30 UFC fighters. Cause I know he would murder each and every one of them,
like he has countless fans.
Would you rather throw up every time someone says McDonald's or wear a
fedora for the rest of your life? And if anybody asks about it,
you have to sincerely say, I just liked the way it looks. that.
No way. Every guy that wears a fedora is a piece of.
Starting with Bert Kreischer. He's the worst.
He wears a dumb hat and no shirt on every show.
And is this gonna actually work? Like it's going to for a year,
but like how long can you do your,
I mean the sleeveless shirts already with Larry, like cable, like, come on,
put the, put a shirt on.
If there were stats available for every aspect of your life,
what three stats would you want to see? Dude? You don't want to see any of them.
It's all bad. I mean, what would be the worst stats then?
Like how many salads have I had single digits, man.
Um, how many hours of sleep do I average?
A night single digits. Um, okay.
But less than five, uh,
I would want to see how much water you drank. I drank in a day.
I think it's like, I average probably like three and a half gallons a day.
How many times I've jerked off? It's probably sad. It's yeah.
It's way less than how many times I've had sex.
How many hours I've wasted watching adult video
content. Would you rather live in a world where everyone,
but you is male or female? Everybody else?
Either all male or all female. What do you mean? That is? The world was like,
Oh, everybody is just one gender. You get to stay male. But everybody's,
you know, everybody's mail. I mean,
I'd take it for a ride. Sure. Like if everybody's female, they have one option,
right? Yeah. Might as well get in there. See what? You can do logic.
And then like what about what I reproduce? They all gonna be? Yeah.
They're all gonna come out. Female too. Yeah.
I can just leave because there's so many, right. You could just be like,
like leave, like it'd be like Viking village where you're just like.
And then be like, I gotta go and you just leave. Yeah. I don't know.
Wouldn't you do that? Wait, what would you do? Hey, nah,
I wish the world was all guys. And then I would be in a fight.
Like I can't wait to have the beat out of me by a world of men. No, that.
How much money would it take for you to not know how? Uh,
a hundred million. Okay, good. I mean, I would just be like,
okay, you read this right. I have a hundred million dollars.
Here's a thousand dollars. Read this to me. Right?
You can't use Twitter. You can't text. Hey, you know how I pay?
You start writing. Isn't that the, yeah, but I,
I think you would need more than that though. More than a hundred million.
If you're going to have to pay someone every single time they need to read for
you. I'll put you on salary. Jesus Christ. Don't you,
you have interns here. I know you guys want to be my reader.
Like you can come with me. Cool places,
get the out of this building and then just reach it. And I'll be like,
Hey, thanks for reading that. Here's a sandwich
you've been put in charge of running. Heck
the afterlife for people not evil enough for hell.
What's the first torture you design.
Oh yeah. It's just, I just have them wait in a lot of lines. You know,
like lines are kind of the worst thing and you know what I would have,
I would make it so that the,
the waiting line that they're in has a bunch of other people having public
speaker phone and FaceTime conversations.
So they're just sitting there and they're like, well, everyone shut the other.
One's like, no, we gotta keep talking. So like,
it's just like just makes them crazy that everyone would shut up.
It might be reserved for help. That's harsh. Perhaps.
That's that's what Garth Brooks is going to suffer one day.
If your belly button was a real button and you could push it once a day to make
anything happen, what would it do right now?
It kind of works as a fart machine. Is that not an option?
Um,
I could make it do anything.
I mean, quarters are always nice to have, you know,
like if you go like this and he's like on the quarter comes out. Yeah.
25 cents a day. I mean, I'm always looking for quarters, dude.
At least like more than $1 is worth six quarters come out.
I got like this and in six quarters I vomit six quarters.
Would you rather walk in on your dad having sex with a dog or a
dog having sex with your dad? Jesus.
Christ.
Um, I'd rather, I think I'd rather see my dad a dog,
you know, than to see a dog mounting. My dad, like,
and my dad kind of look up with that like, like, Hey buddy.
And I'll be like, who are you talking to? You know, like if he the dog,
I'd be like, yeah, we all got our thing, you know? Right.
You're like dad loves to come to. Right. Would you rather,
every time you come,
it comes out of your mouth or it's two liter bottles worth. I got to tell you,
I already do about two liter bottles with I buckets.
It is absolutely revolting and exciting to whoever's on the other side of
it. Like I, it's not an impressive piece of equipment,
but if you want to see a lot of GEs,
any interns, thank you very much.